god bless mommy god bless daddy
god bless the new almond forgotten
someone to keep thinking me I forgot to
bless me
god bless me a to some England's funny
its writer ready to put the smile back
on our people would we fight that war
but it is over what am i doing about it
you're doing what you're good at writing
place had enough of making people laugh
I want to make them see I need to get
out of London somewhere quiet and trying
to think for what you're going to live
here this is your new home from now
mommy says you're writing a book stop
people going toward I think I look at
the door good I did well the only one
that does it really like she roads but
for me I definitely read it shall we go
for a walk
aren't you working it doesn't seem
likely you think is a good name for
donkey in your
because in a minute be in there dancing
you just want to make honey yes I
completely forgot about bees
that is crazy
find something to be happy but I think
I've got something for us
earnest Ania putting your bear in a book
or putting you in it too
what do you call me in the book your
real name Christopher Robin let's be
hunters and snow come on forget rocks by
the creatures in the story of toys their
toys but the woods are real we neither /
it's rather inexplicable yes
beeping Christopher on the front page
why does everyone like we needed to say
much after the war there was so much
sadness then when he became alone shall
we get to the way I could keeps writing
to do I'm afraid he had to be allowed to
grow he had to know his important radio
into the newspaper interview can't do
all this by the NGO doesn't he physical
form
[Music]
12 men black a home I should think
you
you